This is a production of Cornell
University
Hi graduates! Hello from Ithaca!
Congratulations! Can you believe it?
Class of 2020 Ag Sciences!
We are proud of you!
Hey guys, not only are we proud of you. I hope you're proud of yourselves and the
accomplishments you have made over the last four years
or two years.
We are so proud of what you've
accomplished in your time at Cornell.
It's hard to believe this, but you are about to enter a new phase.
You are turning from student to Cornell alum. Welcome to a lifetime relationship
with people from around the world, and
when it comes to ag
sciences -- unless you didn't know this
already --
let me reiterate you now have your
forever home.
Guys, the world needs you. I know
I've had a number of you in my classes.
I've gotten to know pretty well all of
you. Like basically.
I know you, all of you, and i just want to
say that your Cornell training,
I am totally positive has really
prepared you to take on whatever
challenges come
towards you. You know research that
you've been doing,
working with other professors,
critical thinking skills,
time management all the things that you
first took with
us in our introductory course and have
taken on your additional courses. So
please, please, do something to help this planet out. I  have total confidence in all of you.
We have seen you in your best and in your worst. We have walked with you and talked with
you and supported you.
And we want you to know that we have
tremendous faith in you.
You are incredibly resilient.
This is a moment when your resilience
has been tested,
and what you have learned is that you
can do anything.
Be kind to yourself remember to be
flexible
and know that we're here for you.
I'll end by saying I think all of you
know that
I was born in Italy and family in the
Italian culture is extremely important.
And i just want to say that you've all
now become part of 'mia famiglia' and so I
want to say 'benvenuti a la famiglia' which basically
means welcome to the family: the
agricultural sciences family
the Cornell family. You will always be
Cornellians
and always be AgSci majors. So we would
love to
stay in touch with all of you. Please let
Kari and I know what
you're up to down the road, when you have families, no matter where you are in the
world, we'd love to hear from you.
So I'll end by saying congratulations
once again to all of you and to your
families
that have supported you and we look
forward to seeing you.
Congratulations 2020!
This has been a production of Cornell
University,
on the web at cornell dot edu